and we're going to begin with this the
senate getting ready to hold hearings
this morning on a supreme court
nomination that could set the high court
on a new path president trump chose
appeals court judge amy coney barrett to
succeed justice ruth bader ginsburg
who as you know died last month so if
barrett is confirmed it would expand the
court's conservative majority
to six to three and that matters because
there are a number of big issues on the
line from the affordable care act to
abortion rights and the hearing is
expected to be an angry
partisan battle nancy cordes is on
capitol hill for us nancy good morning
to you
what's going to happen when this hearing
begins this morning good morning well
confirmation hearings are typically
four-day affairs and this one for a
supreme court nominee is
no different day one today will be all
about
opening statements both from judge amy
coney barrett herself but also from the
22 members
of the senate judiciary committee some
of whom are furious
that this hearing is happening at all
today's hearing will be the first real
test of the gop
strategy to fast track the nomination of
judge amy coney barrett
weeks before the election her views are
too extreme the delay tactics of the
democrats aren't going to work
great character republicans today will
emphasize her qualifications
the 48-year-old federal appeals court
judge and
notre dame law professor would be the
first mother of school-aged
children to sit on the court in her
opening statement today
judge barrett will say the late
conservative justice antonin scalia
inspired her philosophy that a judge
must apply the law as written
not as the judge wishes it were she
knows
what it is to be a judge and that is to
cloak your personal preferences
democrats will argue that judge barrett
is being rushed onto the court
in time to help strike down obamacare
with a crucial case coming next month
in 2017 barrett published a journal
article
criticizing the rulings that upheld the
affordable care act
a vote for judge barrett is very simple
it's a vote to take
health care away from 20 million
americans in a new letter to the justice
department senate democrats
raised concerns over judge barrett's
candor
citing omissions from her original
disclosure forms
including an anti-abortion advertisement
she signed in 2013.
barrett later submitted the
advertisement to the senate
president trump nominated barrett at a
white house event that has now been
linked to several cases of coronavirus
including two gop senators who sit on
the committee
they're expected to attend remotely
today vice presidential nominee kamala
harris who also sits on the committee
says she'll attend remotely too because
republicans refused to put
covid testing procedures in place
some democrats argue that if republicans
manage to seat a supreme court nominee
this close to the election that they
should respond
by adding seats to the supreme court if
they win the
senate and the white house former vice
president joe biden the democratic
nominee has been
asked repeatedly whether he favors this
plan and he keeps saying tony that he'll
reveal his view
after the election but he has spoken out
against it in the past
nancy thank you very much and when the
confirmation hearing for judge barrett
begins cbs news will bring it to you in
a special report we expect that will
begin around 9 a.m eastern
8 central